how can I say how can I say it's not
it's not
those patients have the patients
everyone's patience is gone now so put
it like this right
um I think what you're trying to say so
with Instagrams Instagram social media's
created a lot of options
um it's created a lot of well perceived
options
um so it's whereas before you would you
know if he was a pretty girl you
wouldn't treat a girl in your school
um when you're in a little area or
whatever and you'll have the local local
people that would have you know
approached you but now with Instagram
you have more attentions from everywhere
and what it tends to do is it can um it
can inflate goals the perception of what
actually
um they value or what's available to
them so for example if you're in a
relationship with a girl and she has an
open Instagram and it's not that means
she can get attention from all different
types of men now particularly if you're
just in a relationship and she's a
girlfriend she's not your wife and
remember you know if she hasn't got a
ring or not technically you're just
you're just there right so Instagram
just creates a place where women can get
opportunities and get messages and they
can get distractions from all different
places and that's just one one aspect of
it we can go way further that but with
social media it just creates some more
interest what do you guys think I agree
what he said yeah yeah I do agree yeah
100 I think
um
sort of like it's
in terms of its ruined would you say
it's ruined a modern woman yeah oh okay
yeah so like if we're looking at the
women in the past so say you're within a
community you only know the people
within your community so if you
have you know done dynamating for
example everyone in that Community is
going to know but now it's like you have
the whole world to just free up yourself
basically so I think it it's definitely
more exposure more you're seeing you're
you're having a lot more like people to
compare yourself to as well and I think
that's problematic for self-esteem so
it's
just a sort of thing yeah so do you
think it makes women have lower
self-esteem yeah 100 yeah depending on
what if you're comparing yourself to
other you're comparing yourself to other
women and yeah so why are women so
addicted to it then I I've listened it's
women that do it to other women like
yeah none of us have ever asked you guys
to get a BBL none of us ever asked you
guys to wear not your natural hair none
of it ever ask you guys to put stuff
into your lip these are all things that
you guys do for you guys so but whenever
a man talks about it they'll say keep
out of women's businesses it's our body
right that's fine but you have to
understand the things that these women
are doing you're creating insecurities
between yourselves because us as men we
don't want these things and the moment
we say we don't want these things it's
like skip out women women's business you
know what I'm trying to say to you no
but men
no but so men always say they don't want
these things but I okay like I'm not
saying I'm Beyonce and I'm not saying
I'm I'm Freddy Krueger ever but I have
never been moved to when I don't have
makeup on yeah I
never
I I've got outside I know people that
run to the shop in their head scarves
and their whatever and they've never
been moved to and you have to understand
the woman that has that look of the BBL
and the
the long Brazilian weave and they get
the more attention they get the most
attention you can just see yourself do
you think it's relationship attention or
sexual attention
and I wouldn't put makeup in the same
category as lip fillers
they do go for the rappers and the
footballers and the rappers and the
footballers that's the look that they go
for right but would you say the rappers
and the footballers or husbands looking
for wives
but I do like them do they see this
would you say would you say rappers
really have wives
or do they have like three baby bombers
I agree and this is the thing if if
you're if you're looking at rappers and
and footballers and people as the your
Target demographic then already what
you're saying is I have to be willing
for a certain type of behavior because
you're going like you're saying you're
going for the top guy right and the top
guy is gonna do certain things and he's
going to look at certain things so for
us I'll say it again
um and I'll make it loud us as men we
want you in a natural state because your
natural hair your natural nails your
natural
um your natural lips these are things
that are going to be passed on the jeans
to my child so whatever you do nice nice
like whatever you do that's how you look
but it's not really how you look see
when I wake up next to you in the
morning that's the real you and I grew
up in a house with three sisters and my
mom so I'm I'm from my African
um background so I'm used to seeing
women with their
um in their natural hair I'm used to
seeing women obviously covered and stuff
stuff like that so for me I would
actually move to you with a headscarf on
because I'll consider you to be
beautiful because my sister is beautiful
for her scarf on right but the problem
is
all of this fakery and stuff is we got
to deal with it so of course if you've
got
for as a black girl why have you got
Chinese man called Brazilian hair coming
out of here so for me I'll be like you
know just keep them keep the normal hair
even if what's that go with afro what's
her name Jess yeah as soon as I came
outside oh I love your hair it's just
because it just looked natural she just
looked natural so for us as men they may
tell you that's not what we want but
trust me you love a natural woman that's
sort of going back to what you said
actually is it a wife or is it just
sexual because like you would want a
wife say the
the you know obviously like Jess you
said yeah but if you were sexually
attracted yeah you just smash the thing
with a Brazilian button of course but
but now you're saying just smashy for
talking smash versus wife now it's
completely different things now if I'm
gonna smash you then I don't really care
about your hair because if
the week the week The Weave come out in
your hand like you're not going to be
bothered about that because that's going
to be experience you're going to talk to
your boy about and say oh this is what
happened but you know you're not going
to care really more than that you see
it's to say something
um no I was gonna say I feel like in
terms of the natural hair thing because
I feel like that is quite a big topic as
well but I feel like as black women
Eastern stand there was a period of time
when eurocentric features were what was
promoted Cooley women were the ones who
were on magazines and the ones who we
were told that we are supposed to look
like you know what I mean so I feel like
as a woman a black woman growing up in a
society where from a young age we've
been programmed to view Beauty in a
certain light
it's hard to manipulate what it's hard
to reprogram what we've been manipulated
to believe we can teach our children but
as a person looking in the mirror
and sometimes it's not even uh like I
feel like wearing fake hair sometimes
it's a protective I'm a protective
hairstyle then because you don't know
who what that person's hair is
underneath and we're not necessarily in
the right country and climate as black
people in general for our hair to
flourish and grow in its natural state
for all of us we're not in our home
country no I hear that in it what I'll
say as a guy right is is you can have a
protective style but let it be a
protective style that is matching
towards your hairstyle or where you're
from so if you want to protect your hair
that's fine but have a have a braid
style have a corner style extension
style and that'll be more natural so
what we're just trying to say is either
way natural will always be better for us
as men but we're always going to be told
that Faker is what we want when in
actual fact we don't want that for the
men need to speak up on that then we
can't speak on women's bodies or hair no
women don't women don't listen to men
when they say what they want I just said
that women women don't women don't
listen because when men say they want
thin women pure women and and women
don't listen they just say that they're
slot shaming and they're not body
positive so it's like when might even
say what they want we don't care I just
think each [ __ ] I own if you want to
wear a wig if you want to wear
braids wear braids I don't think like I
mean there's men out that that genuinely
like women with the long Brazilian hair
and the afro and the braids when the Men
start saying oh
green like a woman that's natural like
that's where women have an issue with it
but wait didn't you just say that men
should speak out on it and now you're
saying they can't I'm not saying but
when you start saying oh we only like
girls with natural hair like that so
we're not allowed to have a preference
or something so so what's happening
again is you say Mentor speaker and I
speak out and I say you know what I like
your hair in that way but you know what
actually what I actually prefer is if
your natural state I think you look more
beautiful than that that's okay that's
okay but then that's okay saying that
but when you start
it's okay he's saying it but when I
start saying it no when you start
putting oh that's what I prefer oh I
like that but that's my preference
preference is pot I think I feel like I
thought Apple eats to their own like if
I just say that we've been given the
choice as women exactly we have been
given choice I completely agree with
that but with that choice comes
repercussions
so the receiver of women is men in that
respect if you want a man you should be
willing to see what that man needs now
if that is the case that that man is
asking I don't prefer women she was
wearing hair extensions he was wearing
weaves that doesn't match her natural
skin color then it is not your place as
a woman to tell that man that he is
wrong for his preference would you say
that um because I've heard from guys
when the girls have like more of the
fake stuff or the bbls or whatever they
put them more in like a casual category
just off the bat yeah come on man
it's so mad to me that you thinking that
putting all these Faker is going to get
your man that actually wants you and you
even have to understand the difference
between someone that wants you for one
night and someone that really wants you
so if I want you for one night I don't
care what you do so you're working come
off and come up in the hand in the
bedroom it doesn't matter like it
doesn't even if
it doesn't matter how you dress in
actual fact the more provocative they're
better because you're letting people
know what you're on but now if I'm
talking about you as my wife you know
all of these things that I wanted you
for one one night would be a red flag
for me there will be things that I
wouldn't I would I wouldn't only read
one and I just gotta think that women
have to ask themselves what do they want
do you see if you want one night that's
fine do a certain thing but if you
actually want long term then the things
that you do for that one night as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible